ist das mag diese geste nicht ran
ich habe keine lust auf psycho gespräche
lasst uns bitte von was anderem reden
sondern freund zum beispiel bis jetzt
hast du ja noch nicht zu viel von ihm
erzählt naja außer dass er unpünktlich
und chaotisch ist und sich mit meiner
mutter versteht aber wer tut das schon
davon abgesehen ist ziemlich süß wie
lange seid ihr denn eigentlich schon
zusammen fast vier jahren
es ist ganz schön lang falls sie denn
nicht heiraten heiraten
es ist glaube ich ein bisschen früh um
darüber nachzudenken und meine mutter
würde das sowieso nicht überleben
ihr fällt es doch schon schwer genug zu
akzeptieren dass ich ausgezogen
essen gibt es nur für die die auch
mithelfen
also los die champignons müssen noch
gewaschen werden
wie geht das noch fragen auf die couch
reza
ich meine das ernst wenn nicht mithilft
die besseren köche hallo also ich bin
neugierig wie luthers freund so ist
hallo
sie können gerne mit essen wenn sie
möchten noch mehr besucher aber wir
haben bestimmt auch was für diabetiker
dabei hatte ja ich hab gesagt wenn prof
hallo mama nicht so schlimm
der satz du durch deine mutter zum essen
eingeladen